so there's a kind of parallel story now
going on in addition to the
investigation into the death of this
journalist from the Washington Post
Jamal khashoggi at the Saudi embassy in
Istanbul Turkey and it relates to the
seeming reluctance of the Trump White
House to just fully say what seems to be
very obviously the reality here which is
that Saudi Arabia was at minimum
directly involved and involved and
likely specifically responsible for the
death of this journalist and we actually
have a poll up on the David Pakman show
YouTube channel community tab at
youtube.com slash the david pakman show
slash community asking you why you think
we are seeing this reluctance from Trump
to just really say what everybody else
is thinking about it and there's a sort
of lying and optional lying unforced
error story that's developing as well
which is that Donald Trump has chosen to
straight up deny that he has any
financial interests in Saudi Arabia the
problem primarily is that he previously
bragged about these financial interests
that he now denies having and it's all
related to the death of journalist Jamal
khashoggi yesterday we were wondering
about what would the White House was
response be to the killing of Jamal
khashoggi by as far as we've most
recently a surmised Saudi Arabian
interrogators inside the Saudi embassy
at in Istanbul Turkey and part of the
skepticism that trump would do anything
serious about it came from his sort of
bizarre parodying of this talking point
that anybody could have killed khashoggi
it could have been quote rogue killers
and then part of our skepticism about
Trump doing a damn thing about this came
from his general attitude towards
authoritarian dictators during his
presidency and towards violent
theocracies which is that he seems to be
quite frankly pretty impressed with them
and usually doesn't criticize them very
much but there is a third angle that
should really make us particularly
skeptical of Trump's handling of the
death in a serious manner which is the
issue of Donald Trump's financial
interests
in Saudi Arabia but also with Saudi
individuals and apparently to try to
sort of get ahead of this Donald Trump
tweeted yesterday that quote for the
record I have no financial interest in
Saudi Arabia or Russia for that matter I
mean why not mention that while you're
at it any suggestion that I have is just
more fake news of which there is plenty
of course not only is this unknown
provable lie Trump himself previously
bragged about doing business with the
Saudis here's just one of many many
examples I could play for you we need to
make great deals with other countries
Saudi Arabia as I like the Saudis
they're very nice I make a lot of money
with them they buy all sorts of my stuff
all kinds of toys from Trump they pay me
millions and hundreds of millions but
you know what they make a billion
dollars a day folks there are a ton of
these I won't bore you with them but
many of these instances where Trump says
I sell stuff to the Saudis I do business
with the Saudis it's all great when
Trump first announced his bid for the
White House in Trump Tower in New York
in 2015 he said I love the Saudis many
are in this building
Trump has tons of deals with the Saudis
Trump World Tower sold the building to
the Saudi government Trump bought a
yacht originally built for a Saudi arms
dealer who happens to be the cousin of
Jamal khashoggi that's a connection that
maybe we will talk more about the crown
prince of Saudi Arabia has been staying
at Trump's hotel on the west side of
Manhattan while Trump has been president
of the United States there's a Saudi
billionaire who bought a yacht from
Trump in 1991 for twenty million dollars
timed by the way to help Donald Trump
stave off personal bankruptcy it's a
very long list so as usual Trump is
lying that's not new but what's
significant is that now it's Russia now
it's also Saudi Arabia where Trump's
personal connections to rich people in
the countries could directly influence
how Trump handles geopolitics and
American policy related to these
countries in this case we're talking
about the reaction to the killing a
Washington Post journalist Jamal
khashoggi it's gone beyond pathological
lies and I was thinking yesterday Pat
wouldn't it sort of be smarter and more
realistic instead of lying and saying I
have no financial involvement with the
Saudis right what if Trump said I have
financial ties to people all over the
world because I'm a successful business
person but I'm the president now and I'm
not gonna let that influence my
decisions like wouldn't that be it would
still not be believable but at least
it's not a demonstrable lie that's what
someone rational would do but you could
go many steps beyond that like Trump
could divest from his businesses and put
his assets into a blind trust so even if
at one time he had ties to the Saudis he
would no longer be influenced by that he
would no longer have a conflict of
interest he could go beyond that - and
released her tax returns but that's a
little pie-in-the-sky at this point
there were actually Trump Astana
internet defending the letter of what
Trump said by arguing that to Donald
Trump the definition of financial ties
might just be something different than
the list of what I told you selling
yachts selling stuff to the Saudi
government in his buildings all maybe -
Trump it's technically what he believes
so it's not a lie it's a semantic
disagreement is that really the best
that you can do to try to argue that
Donald Trump is not lying here the Saudi
financial thing is really serious and a
Saudi Crown Prince Mohammed bin Salman
previously said we covered this it might
have been July I don't remember exactly
Mohammed bin Salman previously said that
he has Donald Trump's son-in-law Jared
Kushner in his pocket okay this is not
without precedent we've already been
concerned about this and what I want to
hear from you about and you can vote on
this on our YouTube community poll what
do you think is the primary driver of
this reluctance from Trump to really go
after Saudi Arabia here youtube.com
slash the david pakman show slash
community and you can vote there or
maybe we will have results in a few days
on an upcoming show